If Mozu-chan and I, the kids, team up, we'll be
able to gain control of this island, luxury, and everything else. I do
n't think so.
This naturally leads to moving to the next position,
and that's what
Tenno will
do.If the strength of Mentalist Daigo-chan, Baibara-chan, and other soldiers is 100, then of course
Chan is already around 150.  Is
n't it? No, it's not like that.
Yes, there may be a little more difference.
Mentorist game's mind manipulation
techniques. When I say data that is slightly off the mark, I feel like I have to correct it, so I don't
want to ride it in the first place.  I'm going to go along with the story, but
in reality, if I had to compare it to Tee, it would probably be his arm.I wish he were that strong.I
feel like he could easily defeat someone like
me.  Either I should kill them all or kill them all.I